في ملابسات اقتحام مبنى الكابيتال تصريحات
مثيره للجدل اعلنت عنها ابنه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ورطت والدها في سياسه
التحريض على العنف والسعي الى قلب الخساره
في انتخابات 2020
ايفانكا ترامب وامام لجنه التحقيق كشفت عن
الاتصالات سريه بين والدها ونائب الرئيس
مايك فانس بالمكتب البيضاوي كان هدفها
ايجاد طرق انتم تساهم في قلب خسارتهما
الانتخابيه ابرزها محادثه هاتفيه ساخنه
جدا تمحورت حول دور برنسيس في التصديق على
التصويت الانتخابي في مجلس الشيوخ والتي
انتهت بطرح خطه رفده عليها ما ادى لسوء
العلاقه بين الطرفين
كان هناك نقاش حول ماهيه حقوق نائب الرئيس
بخصوص منصبه والتزاماته في رئاسه مجلس
الشيوخ لهجه والدي كانت مختلفه مع مايك
بينس ولقد احزنني ان اراهم على خلاف
اكدت بانها
انصار الرئيس السابق مبنى الكابيتل
احتجاجا على نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
كان من طرف احد كبار مستشار البيت الابيض
والذي وصفته فيما بعد بالصادم وغير
المقبول حيث اشارت ايفانكا ترامب الى وجود
نقاش حول ماهيه حقوق نائب الرئيس في منصبه
في رئاسه مجلس الشيوخ بلهجه تصعيديه وهو
ما ادى لتازم العلاقه بين والدها ومايكل
تصريحاته ايفانكا ترامب وضعت مسار والدها
السياسي على طريق المجهول والذي على ما
يبدو يحاول اعاده التجديده بعد اعلان
ترشحه
خاباتي المقبله
[تصفيق]